Welcome back everyone
It's Charlie
This will be my full Loki Season 2
Episode 1 Video.
There were a whole bunch of Easter eggs
and references.
Obviously,
we know this is going to cross over
with Deadpool 3,
so I'll explain how some of those
connections worked during the video too.
If you're brand new to the channel, be
sure to subscribe to get all the episodes
we're also doing a Loki giveaway
for Blu rays during the episode videos.
All you have to do to enter
is be a subscriber.
You just post all your predictions
for Loki.
Season two but careful for spoilers.
If you haven't seen the episode yet,
we'll just start at the beginning, work
our way through, shot by shot,
talking about Easter eggs and WTF moments,
starting with the episode title
Ora Burrows, which is a reference
to Kahui Quan's new TV character
in the concept just in general of Aurora's
time, repeating the name
or Boris also means time eater timeline
eating itself basically meant to flow
with the whole idea of the time
slipping storyline in episode one.
In the timeline itself, rebooting
after he who remains was killed by Sylvie,
then then trying to literally fix
the actual physical timeline itself.
they start with an updated version
of the Marvel Studios logo.
They usually update the Marvel Studios
intro logos
every time there's a brand new series
or brand new movie,
just incorporating the brand new
characters into it
for whatever comes next.
so this is coming
after the Secret Invasion series,
we have Emilia Clarke's
Gaia character, for instance.
the actual opening scene begins
in the exact moments of the season one
finale with Loki going on the run
because Mobius, the others don't know him
because he time slipped
into the past of the TVA
and none of those characters
had actually met him yet.
So they just treat him
like a normal variant.
Oh, we have to arrest him.
and in the past, apparently he remains.
King wasn't hiding his identity
from all the different TVA agents.
Just at some point in the future,
he decided to create the timekeepers
so that he could withdraw to his citadel
at the end of time,
he winds up jumping a TBS
mail truck trying to escape,
nearly crashes into Cassie
and really big Easter egg here, too,
because Casey is apparently
having some insomnia issues,
But he's listening to the same
Staying Awake podcast
that Stephen Grant was listening
to during the Moon Night series.
but you notice
this version of the TVA control room
is a little bit different
because his earlier in the timeline,
he winds up cracking the TVA
symbol in the floor
so they recognize
what happened in the future.
Like, wait a minute, I just did that
But basically the idea is that he's gone
out of sync with the timeline
because of what happened
with all the different timelines,
freeing in the device that processes
raw time into he who remains
sacred timeline like this is how
he actually created the sacred timeline.
Like there's a device
that literally creates
isn't designed to handle
all the different branches
and if it were to theoretically explore
basically all time
in space would collapse on itself
one way to destroy the multiverse.
I cannot wait to see how Loki and Sylvie
destroy the multiverse this season.
Like each season, it gets a little bit
worse, each different Marvel character
just trying to blame each other
who's trying to destroy reality?
The fastest Doctor Strange.
With his incursions,
You have Loki and Sylvie
freeing the counsel of kings,
all these different variants.
Then you have Deadpool, who is probably
really going to mess up the multiverse.
not to leave Spider-Man
out of this either.
Then during
the special Loki version of the intro,
they have the same Loki theme music
from season one.
It's the same basic shifting Loki titles,
all the different characters
in the Loki name.
That shift
or get to represent the different
Loki variants
back in the control room,
Mobius and Hunter B-15
are in the aftermath of the season
one finale.
Like this is still present day.
The timelines are going
all over the place, all wonky because he
remains is dead.
And all the time
I have been free in there trying
to figure out what to do about this.
Like, should we tell everybody that
they're variants? We should, shouldn't we?
Basically, the
entire TVA is thrown into complete chaos.
They get into this with the TVA judges
council on the second.
Don't we all talk about that?
Because I think there are
a couple of twists that they throw at us,
there might be a character
who's not exactly who they say they are.
Mobius tries to use Ms.
Minutes to track down Loki, even though
we know she's super sinister now.
And they explain that she's not functional
because they basically killed
he remains king.
And I think that's
what made this version of Ms.
minutes to go inactive.
but what they did at the end of time
affects Ms.
minutes across the entire timeline.
So that's
why even back during the present here
when they come back to present day Ms.
Minutes is the same across all points
in time and space so they disable Ms.
minutes in the future.
It also disables her
across the entire timeline,
but because we have all the King
variants like
we have the victor timely king
He has his own version of Ms..
And it looks a little bit different.
So we'll see.
Ms.. Minutes come back
during the season in different ways.
they have a real big callback
to Mobius as jetskis from season one
when another agent Hunter X5
gets all interested in his magazine.
really making you wonder if they're going
to put Mobius on a jet ski eventually
because he is really technical on jetskis.
maybe
they'll save that for like Deadpool three
because we know he's
going to be in the Deadpool three movie.
That feels like a really wacky thing,
like actually putting him on a Jet Ski.
you might recognize Hunter X five here.
He's played by Brad Wolfe, who also shows
up in the trailer at the Zany movie
premiere that might be a variant of X5
or it might be the actual X5.
we don't really know yet.
He just seems a little bit sus, as does
General Docs, who's kind of treating him
like Mommy's special boy.
There's something weird going on
with those two characters,
so keep your eye on Hunter five.
He explains that
because Ren Slayer has vanished
and they know what Ren Slayer did.
Look, the other judges know what she did.
The other ones are trying to decide
on the judge's council what to do next.
General Docks and Judge Gamble,
for instance.
There's another judge there,
but he's asleep most of the time.
So just kind of a joke. Like he's
just barely awake.
Moby is then runs into one of the other
hunters who pruned him last season on Ren
Slayer's orders. very apologetic.
Seems like water under the bridge,
though, Like, Oh yeah, yeah, whatever.
in when Loki slips back to the past,
he goes into the war room.
There's this mural of Kang Faces,
but it's he remains king.
The multiple faces, though, are also meant
to represent the different Kang variants.
Basically the whole concept
of the Council of Kings.
back in present day in the war room,
the TVA Judges Council is just deciding
what to do about everything
that just happened.
Loki's message about them all
being variants, whether or not they think
it's true, and for the most part
the council decides that it is true
because they do look at evidence like, Oh,
this other hunter said
that they saw
a variant of these other characters.
but the real big thing here
is that General Docs, who's basically
in charge of the TVA right now, is played
by Kate Dickie from Game of Thrones.
Most of you remember is Lisa Aaron.
She was crazy on that series.
I cannot wait to see what kind of havoc
she wreaks on Loki.
She's probably pretty fun.
the rumor about her character right
now, too, in there are a couple moments
during the episode that kind of support
this evidence
is that she secretly might wind up
being an older
variant of Sylvie just pretending to be
this General Doc's character.
We'll see about that.
But there are a couple of moments
during the episode
and some evidence
that she's not who she says she is
and she has information
that the other people don't have that
only Sylvie would have this time, though,
in this version of the War
Room, in present day,
kings faces have been covered up
by the timekeepers
because it's after
he created the concept of the timekeepers
and one of their heads is on the table
from season one where they cut it off.
they're couple their faces around the TVA
walls, too.
They're meant to depict the other judges
that are ruling over the TVA, like this
judge's face is behind her on the wall.
you notice the lights on the table, too.
In the middle,
they represent the actual timeline.
You can see the little lights branching
out, showing you the branching timelines.
It's the war room
and it's basically the map of the timeline
in its current state.
Then we get a really big info dump
on King in Raven translators BackStory.
So Loki starts using the old school
tape player.
These are actually really cool.
They're actually worth a lot of money now
because this is in the past, it's like
right up to the creation of the TVA.
He hasn't created the timekeepers,
so he isn't hiding who he is.
that's
why there's a recording of this here,
because this is like the distant past.
he drops a really big Marvel
Comics reference saying that you are
a marvel, quote
unquote, Raven Arryn Slayer.
it explains that she was very helpful
to him winning the Kang Multiverse War,
confirming that she was a big part of that
first King multiverse war,
Now we learn
that she's a variant from present day.
So I think the idea is
they came from the distant future,
started fighting the Kang Multiverse War.
Then at some point,
he traveled to the past, met her,
and then pulled her out of time,
and she started working with him
in sort of their relationship
But basically he's telling her, I'd
be happy to rule over the TVA with you.
And it's basically the beginning
of their comic book relationship
because in the comics
they are a love interest.
this is planes, How she survived.
At the end of season one,
she got a mysterious message,
quote unquote, that Ms..
Menace gave her from he remains king.
And it was basically him
telling his love interest,
whose mind he'd wiped multiple times prior
at this point,
because you didn't seemingly
remember all that stuff,
giving her an escape route
like you need to jump to this time portal.
Follow my instructions
if you want to survive.
she'll show up later in the season
with Victor Timely.
Kang So I think that'll explain a little
bit more about her backstory with Kang,
Then Loki jumps back to present day
in the War room and reveals the Kang bases
behind the timekeepers in everybody
for the most part, starts to believe
what he's saying. Like, as crazy
as it sounds.
Oh, this is all like
the timekeepers are fake.
now, here's where we get to the mystery
of General Doc's in her motivations.
so after they all agree to stop
pruning alternate timelines, like, okay,
we need to stop doing this right now.
We're killing innocent people.
General Doc's immediately
goes on the warpath and says,
we need to get Sylvie right now
and makes a reference to the end of time
when nobody actually in the room
had ever referenced killing
being at the end of time.
Loki didn't even tell them the truth about
he who remains at the end of time
till later in the episode.
So she knew before that the only way
that she would know about
that is if she was either Sylvie herself,
like an older version of Sylvie,
or if she was also from the future.
so just seems like
she has some special information
and she particularly takes an interest
in Sylvie, like she sends a legion of
hunters after Sylvie,
I think to prevent her
from wreaking more havoc
because this older version of Sylvie
maybe could be another character,
wants to prevent younger
Sylvie from doing whatever it is
that they're doing this season.
either way, it just seems like the focus
now is on this older general.
Doc's like, You really need to keep an eye
on her and what's going on with Sylvie.
Storyline this season,
But basically this older character
is meant to be
the main antagonist of the season.
It won't be another Kang very like Victor,
Timely Kang isn't meant to be the main
villain.
It's not going to be
another variant of King.
The Council of Kings will be involved,
but they won't be the main villains
My only theory is that we'll find out
who General Docks really is
by like episode four or episode five.
All perhaps some more evidence
before that post
all your theories in the comments below.
Like clearly
she is not who she says she is.
Then Loki continues to recap the finale
for Mobius with Ally at the Citadel.
At the end of time
they stand at a mural, the timekeepers
depicting the Kang Multiverse War
and Loki kind of explains that too.
Like, Look,
all the Kang variants are coming.
There's going to be a new Kang
Multiverse war,
basically describing the events
of what will happen during Avengers
Qing Dynasty with the Council of Kings
coming for the main Avengers.
They've a lot of great chemistry together,
like a lot of regular scenes of them
just talking like pros
in a couple of funny moments
with Loki calling his fight
with Sylvie at the end of time
a draw when Mobius suggests that she went,
No, no, no, it was a draw.
What are you talking about?
I wasn't trying to fight her.
I could have totally won
if I was trying to fight her.
that's part of that old hubris joke.
Like Loki thinks of himself
always as the superior Loki They got like,
Who is the best Loki variant?
They call it the superior Loki.
But the bigger joke
is that every Loki variant
thinks of themself as the superior Loki.
He makes sure to tell Mobius
that Miss Menace is totally like
don't try to use your tempered here
to get more information from her
because your pride deceive you.
But she's not working anyway,
because I explained earlier,
she's basically been disabled
across the entire timeline.
The Mobius
takes into the basement of the TVA.
Like the very bottom level of the TVA
where Aura borrows works,
Quick wants character.
The interesting thing
about how he came on the series,
he actually said that after everything
everywhere, all at once came out,
the very first person in all of Hollywood
called him to either
congratulate him or call him for
any reason was Kevin Feige,
who called to say how awesome he was into
Please join the MCU in a project.
in that
just wound up being Loki season two
because they were getting ready
to start filming that.
So far he's great. I love his energy.
He feels like
he steals all the scenes that he's in,
it'll be fun to see what he does
for the rest of the series.
but the whole idea is that he's
meant to have created all the TVA's
technology,
built everything, even created the manual
for how everything works across the TVA,
every minor to major system
with Kang's help,
like he was there at the very beginning.
They explain the whole concept of Loki's
time slipping and how he's out of sync
with time itself And it's all because
of the branching timelines, overloading
this processing device that turns raw
time into the actual timeline.
They're couple funny moments
with Loki's time slipping to that.
They kind of play on this idea
where he learns things in the past
and then you see the timeline
correct in present day.
And he certainly starts
remembering things like,
Oh yeah, I actually did meet
that Loki person.
I did create this device,
They call it a temporal oral extractor.
end, they're basically going to prove Loki
and then pull him,
separate him from the timeline
and hopefully that's going to resync him.
the only thing about that
is they explain during season one
when you prune someone, it automatically
sends them to the void planet.
But I think the way around explaining that
is that this temporal extractor device
basically rips Loki from all points
in time and space in the timeline.
So it doesn't really matter where he is.
so when they use it doesn't really matter
if he's in the distant future
on this void planet,
he could be anywhere in the timeline in
the device would still work
there are bunch of power surges
across the TVA and they basically let
you know that if they don't
fix the actual timeline device here,
everything is going to be ripped apart.
The timeline itself
will just completely blow up all of time
and space will collapse on itself.
there couple moments during the episode
where you actually see the readout
on the main screen
and it looks like that's about to happen
like The timeline
looks like it's about done.
the interesting thing
here, though, on the door is
when they were opening with the shape
here, the eye in the center
reminded me of the door
to Cerebro in all the X-Men movies.
And we do have X-Men showing up Frozen.
They just announce that they're working
on the actual X-Men solo movie.
maybe we'll see some Easter eggs for
mutants at some point during the season.
They keep talking about mutants
like we have Namor from Black Panther
Wakanda forever.
We have the Miss Marvel character.
We'll see more mutants
before the X-Men solo movie happens.
They explained that before
the events of season one, Miss Minutes
had run everything on her own,
and now she's out of commission.
So it's got all chaotic, freeing
all the timelines, infinite branches,
everything going crazy in the basic
solution is this just retrofit this
so that it can handle
all the branching timelines
so that you don't have to prune
all these alternate timelines
like they used to do in the TVA.
Mobius suits up
on one of those giant spacesuits,
but they put a bunch of duct tape on it.
Turns out duct tape can help fix anything,
even super advanced technology.
I'm sure there's a bunch of
king variants out there fighting the King
Multiverse war, using duct tape to do it,
going to flex tape. The universe.
This time Loki time slips into the future
but loses the pruning one.
But here's the thing Gets a phone call it.
Finds Sylvie prying
open the doors to an elevator
and it's Sylvie that saves them
by pruning him just in time.
So we know a lot of people are like,
Wait a minute,
when did Sylvie come from in the timeline?
Like, how did she wind up here?
thinking about typical time travel tropes,
I think that this Sylvie that saved him
on the elevator here was from the future,
and she knew it was going to happen
or someone told her.
So she went back to this moment
so that she could save him.
that doesn't explain
who was trying to call him on the phone
in that
actually might way too early theory.
It was actually Loki himself
from the future.
It was trying to warn him about everything
was happening with Sylvie this season.
And that gets into
the whole General Doc's plot.
Either way, this was not also Sylvie
that was calling him then is they save
Loki.
General Docs takes a legion
worth of hunters after Sylvie,
like I said, really says
keep an eye on her.
then during the end credits, it's
the same style as the season one credits.
But all the scenes they depict are new.
this is Loki's file.
There's a Time Keeper head on the war room
from earlier in the episode.
Some of the stuff is from future
episodes too.
Like there's a TV, a keyboard typewriter,
all the sticky notes reference events
that happened in this episode.
Probably in future episodes too.
There are a lot of tropes,
the time travel stories on these,
like this one says Ambulance curse,
one says Pool of Deception
Dream State Parallax
once is fleksy and calendar.
Let me know if you think you spotted
any other Easter eggs
in a lot of these messages here.
Some of them,
I think are meant to be kind of random
there's another batch of case
reports, the TVA symbol on the floor.
It's meant to look like Kang's face
with his two eyes in the symbol of time
between them, like the hourglass
between them turned into a sword.
in the metaphor is Kang
using time as a weapon.
that's the funny thing is that like Kang
was there the whole time.
This has been the TVA symbol
the whole time.
Even though he hid behind the timekeepers,
at some point,
the symbol was always there.
It was always Kang Space.
He was always watching them at all times.
Everywhere.
the key lime pie is from the automat.
I think that's a moment from episode two.
There's another monitor
with Ms. minutes on it.
This looks like the blueprints
for the machine that converted raw time
into the sacred timeline.
Like they were actually building
the device itself in the first place.
the book on black holes
is meant to be a funny callback
to the joke about turning into spaghetti
when you fall into one.
They're more buttons,
and the automat seeing all this food.
All this coffee
actually makes me want some of it.
Now there's the old school
tape deck with that
recording, providing more backstory
about Raven, a Wren, Slayer, and Kang,
the TVA system's going all haywire.
Not sure who the monkey belongs to.
get on the desk, there's files
with pictures of Loki, General Doc
55 or A borrows the other judge.
But notice
there's no file with Mobius on it.
So these might be Mobius files.
And I'm just collecting evidence, trying
to figure out the connection
between all the characters.
There's a flash of Sylvia's
McDonald's from the 1980s.
There's a temp pad
that's gone haywire with Ms.
Minutes telling them, nope, like, nope,
we're done. This is it.
they're couple shots of.
He remains citadel at the end of time
after the events of his death
because we know we're going back there.
I think in episode two,
they reference that during general
doctor's conversation in the war room,
she said, we need to go to the end of time
to find out what happened.
the like I said, at that point,
Loki hadn't revealed that part
of the story, so she would have only known
if she was either from the future
or if she was a version of Sylvie herself.
still a lot of questions
with her character.
then I'm not sure what the Zintan
contingent is a reference to.
There's no Marvel characters named Z10.
This seems like a reference to something
that will happen later this season.
But let me know in the comments.
If you think the Z10 is something
from Marvel Comics,
there's a quick shot of the TVA handbook,
which they joked contained
detailed instructions
on every single thing in the TB.
Like if you have a question,
it's answered in this book
and apparently nobody ever bothers
to read the manual,
which is just a real life thing. Like
this is a joke on people in real life.
Nobody ever bothers to read manuals
when they're trying to build stuff.
there was a funny video of Henry Cavill
building a computer
that I posted a long time ago,
and everybody freaked out
when they saw him in the video
reading the manual, like,
look at the jigsaw Chad
reading the manual to build that.
Then they have a post-credits scene
to explain what happened to Sylvie
after the end of season one.
So example this Sylvie is the Sylvie
that just left this moment right here
at the end of time, not the Sylvie
that saved Loki in the elevator
That's why we'll find out
where this Sylvie came from in the future.
In a future episode,
when she eventually joins the team again.
this. Sylvie is meant to leave.
He who remained citadel
after he died, travels to a new branch
timeline in Brockton, Ohio, 1982
and wanders in to a random McDonald's.
This is how the showrunner explains
why she stays at the McDonald's and starts
working there.
Like she says, I'll have everything in
the whole idea is a play
on McDonald's slogan
McDonald's the Happiest Place on Earth.
The idea is that
Sylvie is trying to hide out
in the happiest possible place on earth.
And she thinks that this is McDonald's
the way they said they came up with.
That idea is that Sylvie herself,
when she was growing up,
she was always on the run.
She never had any birthdays
or like happy memories with people.
It was always just day to day with her.
it's this way
when she walks into the McDonald's
and she starts looking around,
seeing people just enjoying themselves,
having fun, like birthday parties, couples
having a nice time together,
a bunch of friends celebrating together.
And she just wants to around
that kind of positive energy.
it'll be funny to see how Loki tries
to explain why she needs to come back.
before the season came out.
They also had a bunch of funny McDonald's
promos with them coming to the McDonald's
and finding her.
I think some of this is a footage
from episode two.
this little special sauce
that was branded as Loki sauce,
but it was just regular McDonald's
special sauce.
they even turned a Brooklyn McDonald's
into like the 1980s
branded Loki version of McDonald's
for a couple of weeks.
Let me know in the comments if you ever
got your hands on that special Loki sauce.
just to explain the Deadpool of this all.
The whole idea is that the TVA is meant
to be a big character or characters
multiple during Deadpool three deadpool's
hopping around the different timelines
he gets on the TVA list.
but the movie
is meant to directly set up Avengers
six secret wars.
In the whole idea is the TVA is rescuing
people from different universes
that are collapsing
because the incursions,
it just puts them all on
what's going to be the MCU battle world.
I'm not expecting Deadpool himself
to actually show up
during the Loki episodes,
but there might be some references
to this in the background
towards the end of the season,
maybe some kind of post-credits scene.
And I think the Tom Hiddleston film
some scenes for Deadpool three,
but we do know that Mobius
and Miss Minutes will be in the movie
in a couple of the other Hunter
characters.
there was a bunch of stuff
going on in the episode,
a bunch of things
that they were setting up for this season.
So if you spotted
any other Easter eggs or references
or you have any questions
about the episode that it didn't talk
about during this video,
just write them below in the comments.
my episode 2 trailer video
we'll post Saturday morning.
They're also doing the boys
join the episodes, so my Gen V episodes
will post like Friday nights
after I post my Loki episodes every week
click here for that
episode 2 trailer video.
I think the link as soon as I post
that and click here for my new Ahsoka
Season 2 video.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe and maximum effort!